welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm very excited to be joined by
donovan pineatello who is one of the
founders of a global specialist sap
recruitment agency
called nicholas bernard and donovan
formed this agency
10 years ago by himself but from 2013 he
has been growing this business
with his business partner richard onyewa
for the last seven years they currently
have
13 employees in the business and last
year
turned over just under 8 million
donovan thanks for joining me thank you
for having me on uh
this podcast hm i've been listening to
it for the last
year and a half really and um yeah thank
you very much you've added a lot of
value to uh this recruitment space
i appreciate donovan and uh safe to say
we just practiced three or four times
the names
before we did that but where i went
where i want to start donovan the first
question
is in your opinion what characteristics
and traits do you
think make up a highly successful
recruitment consultant
well characteristics first and foremost
you need to be hungry
you know everyone says that they want it
but when it comes down to the actions
you really see how hungry
how hungry they are so it's got to be
number one for me is hunger
determination
and there needs to be a reason why that
person wants to achieve it
do you think that hunger can be taught
definitely not
really definitely not no it's
hunger is a character trait it's it's
either you're born with hunger
or your circumstances in life is going
to
give you a reason to have hunger but you
can't teach someone to have hunger
you can teach someone
skills a process um
an industry sector but you can't teach
hunger it's either you've got hunger or
it's
either you're um it's either you're put
into a situation where you develop
hunger
but it definitely can't be taught do you
think and
so just interested on this so um i think
safe to say a lot of the younger
generation get
a bad reputation for not being as hungry
or not wanting to work as hard or
whatever would you agree with that
i've seen it yeah i would agree with it
to a certain extent yeah
really interesting so um
look donovan so what we're going to
focus on today is definitely
sort of donovan's recruitment business
owner journey
and obviously that that spans over um 10
years
but obviously before that from from what
i can see you worked as
an employed recruiter for over five
years
right before you got to that to that
point of starting your own business
yeah so um let me just just start
here what what gave you the confidence
to go out on your own
and start a recruitment business i think
that's what a lot of people
lack that confidence or the willingness
to take that jump
so what what would you say looking back
gave you the
the confidence to to start your
recruitment entrepreneur journey
well to be quite honest i always knew
from when i was at university that one
day i was going to have my business
and my own business and i didn't know
what in
but i always knew that i would be
running my own company one day
and i did international business with
languages
at university and it so happened that i
managed to get into
international recruitment where i use
languages almost
what languages do you speak so speaking
italian french and spanish
really yeah well i didn't know that
definitely um i mean with a name like
that i guess people would expect it
[Laughter]
no no when they see me they definitely
don't accept it
okay so you got into that and then okay
in international recruitment
utilizing your bilingual skills yeah
because i first started off doing
telecoms recruitment for the south
american market
uh works at company called the blue
group which got bought out by mawson's
international
and then um this was in 2004
and then i went in doing um sap
recruitment
for a company called square one in 2006
and it was all international based i've
only ever done international recruitment
contracts that's interesting so always
so you've always done contract
recruitment
international markets and if you always
utilize your bilingual
no really yeah yeah so when i was
recruiting um for um
telecoms in south america it was uh
spanish speaking
even uh i was doing the brazilian market
and
i would speak slowly to clients in
spanish
and they would answer me slowly very
slowly in portuguese that we could
understand each other
and uh yeah i'll be closing deals like
that
amazing yeah managed to do a client
visit in brazil once
really that's awesome so where did this
hunger
for your own business come from then
talk to me what what did you have
parents who were entrepreneurial did you
did you think that was the only
way to build a life that you wanted to
provide yourself and
your family like where where did that
that hunger come from
um to be quite honest my you know
i didn't come from any privileged
backgrounds my parents
had to struggle in life and
yeah that that was always just
drummed into me that you've got to work
harder than everyone in life
you've got to do things to become
somebody and achieve
you know a certain certain status and
achieve big things in life basically so
my mom always drum that into me from a
young age so
i guess i always knew that if i wanted
to
do things then i would have to work and
yeah
what better way than work for your own
self yeah for sure
so um before you started nicholas
bernard went out on your own
yeah so you worked a business for nearly
four years before you
you too took the leap so i guess
what what sort of things happened for
you to be like right i'm going to do
this on my own did you have a really
good
good year did you think right why why
can't i do this for myself i'm making
this company money
was there anything in particular that
gave you the confidence to
start this venture to be quite honest
um before i set up i had some up and
down years
so i had a good spell at the blue group
um
i was doing telecoms recruitment i got a
bit fed up of
you know just doing the the difference
hours because i was doing south american
or u.s hours
and at the time the the us dollar was a
very
low when you converted it back to pounds
which meant the commissions were quite
low
so i wanted to do something more you
know european focused
um i went to square one and then i went
to
um company called spring technology
which was then bought out by a deco
and then the financial crisis hit
and i was specializing at the time
placing sap concerns into banks you know
so i went from
zero to zero literally overnight
and um yeah i ended up i i left
spring and then went to some absolute
[ __ ] shows and i thought
you know i went to a company in
particular which i thought i could just
do a better job with my eyes closed so
yeah i just thought i'm gonna do it
so let's break down this journey then
because we're talking about this before
so at the beginning i think you'd agree
that you
it was a bit of a lifestyle business
right and that was
the first couple of years it was just
you and working from home
and then and then yeah from your bedroom
so
just for content so first two three that
was that
and then obviously 2013 and as i
explained the introduction richard then
came on as your business partner again
as we discussed then
obviously the both of you then building
up some traction for nicholas bernard
and
making sure that this is a business that
you can grow and then for the last
sort of um three to four years you then
focused on
on growth and hiring people etc yeah
so let's just let's just focus on
just quickly the early days yeah right
because obviously
you're working from home in your bedroom
and then you also had a
um muay thai so would you
do muay thai professionally at that
point or yeah so
i i did muay thai back in early 2000's
and
you know i focused on university and
starting out in recruitment and i bought
my flat my first flat in 2005 or
yeah 2005 it was so you know i stopped
all of that and then i went back to it
when
in 2010 when i had um started or set up
nicholas bernard from home where i had a
bit more flexibility and it was
essentially
a bit more of a lifestyle business and
um yeah i used to train twice a day
yes six days per week and
i ended up fighting in thailand i had
nine amateur fights and about six
professional fights at the o2
indigo a skylar in um
in kings cross and that coco's in canada
palace
um i fought under a gym called team two
at gym box so it was um you know it was
it was quite good because i would
get the training to bank in the morning
go to gym box
train go to shoreditch where our office
was
and uh yeah crack one in the evenings
how long did you do that for
the whole fighting thing probably about
four years
okay yeah it was um yeah
so interesting tough time yeah for sure
so like
so let's just talk a bit about i'd love
to just sort of
for you to share the sort of comparisons
that you see in
sort of being in that environment
training fighting and how that's
translated into donovan
business because for me i i'm a huge fan
of them
mma yeah i've only done like five
brazilian jiu jitsu classes and i hurt
my knee and handed back so that's my i
used to do karate when i was a kid
but for me what i absolutely love about
um watching mma and have the utmost
respect for you is that
when you're in that and we spoke about
this before but like when you're in that
environment where
you're in an amateur fight professional
fight um
you're in complete survival mode that
like that the only thing
you the only thing that you can be is
present
and and like completely focus on the
task at hand
right so i'm sure there's been you've
been in
deep uncomfortable situations and all
these sorts of things but
we'd love you to share i don't have many
people in here from a background like
that
um on this show so like for you looking
at your sort of um
business career and your entrepreneurial
journey how
what similarities do you see in donovan
muay thai fighter doing that going into
those
those fights and being a business owner
how's it helped you
well it's do or die isn't it so when you
set up your company
you have to do deals or you die when
you're
in combat it's either you do them
or you get done you know so
there's a lot of there's a lot of
there's a lot of similarities between
the both because
they're both about strategy and having
discipline if you don't have
discipline in a business you're probably
not going to lay down the foundations
that allow you to grow your business
you're not going to
you know do the the rounds the
groundwork you're not going to call your
candidates
your kpis add your contacts just like
when you're
a professional fighter or a professional
athletes you've got to do your cardio
you've got to get your technique up
you've got to think of your brain and
get your strategies because you know
just like you can't just call any client
and say okay well
have you got any jobs you know i'm
donovan from nicholas bernardo supply
consultants
have you got any jobs you've got to come
with a strategy so
you've got to find
a unique selling point you've got to
find market information speak to
candidates if you're targeting for
example
you know bp speak to all the candidates
at bp and understand what's going on at
bp and then call the manager and say
look i know that you're doing this
you're doing that if you're fighting an
opponent and you know that he's
a boxer or a kicker or he's going to
have you in the clinch
you've got to play or you've got to be
able to stifle their strategy so
you know it's um they're both
they're both very similar in the way
that every day
is an attack is a day that you have to
fight for survival
especially in business you know so
the bigger companies are more equipped
to
you know fight for that territory for
that market share for that client
you know so it's a question of you know
fighting them off
and you've got to be have that same
mindset as you're going into battle
you know every day you've got to believe
in your capabilities believe in your
system
and apply everything that you believe in
for you to be able to realize that
success and that tiny step towards
being closer to your goals you know
i like it strategy discipline mindset
yeah 100
i mean discipline to anything is the key
if you're losing weight
if you're wanting to learn an instrument
if you know you want to take up a new
sport
it's all about discipline isn't it
donovan why do you think people fail at
discipline because i think everyone
listening would know
i think everyone knows how to lose
weight everyone knows how they could be
better or
improved but obviously you hear
consistency as king and discipline like
like what why do you think and like
you've obviously being
a fighter that's something that you'd
you would have to be non-negotiable with
your discipline otherwise
when you turn up to fight day there's a
good chance that
you're gonna get knocked out or yeah you
could be seriously hurt or
when you turn up to go on the scales and
you do your weigh-in if you haven't been
disciplined then
you might not be able to fight and you
might not be able to earn the money that
you've been working on whatever right so
why i'll just be interested to get your
thoughts on that like why
why do you think people fail at
discipline
i think people have just been wrapped
around in cotton wall a bit too much
some people aren't really prepared to go
through the depths
and probably put themselves in in
comfort
situations you grow when you're out of
your comfort zone
you know if you're if you're starting
out and
you're scared of rejection you're never
going to understand
how to get around the rejections you've
got to be able to just
you know not take it to heart you know
in anything you do
you you have to if it's easy you're
never going to learn
you know a client's never going to
answer all your calls
it's probably going to take them
probably it's probably going to take you
10 times to call them and then they
answer and then
when you speak to them five six times or
eight times
then they're going to start to remember
you and
probably start to buy from you so i
think that people
are probably they need to condition
themselves more into
this is hard not anyone can do this
and you need to be resilient and carry
on
and eventually it will all add up as a
compound effect
to you know creating that picture
yeah i think the just the interesting
point on that is like i think
a lot of people assume i think this sort
of gym and working out and stuff is is
just a good analogy but
like if i was to look at you donovan
like wow he he works out a lot he looks
in great shape he must find it easier
than i do
or for example running for example a lot
of people may look at people that do
amazing runs and all that and go they
must really enjoy running but
i'm sure hopefully you agree but i can
relate to running where i used to be the
person
i'd say i hated running but
yeah but it's the people that it's not
it's not so it's the mindset of
okay yeah you might hate it but it's
those that push through that and
still do it isn't that it's absolutely
that's so it's like you don't assume
that
people like you might look at someone oh
my god they're so good at business
development i'm finding really difficult
blah blah they must find it easy
we actually know they've pushed through
that discomfort to give themselves more
of an opportunity to find it more
comfortable
or be more competent in the
uncomfortability do you know what i mean
absolutely yeah and look there's some
elements of
recruitment that i don't like to do you
know
but i know that has to be done you know
if
you you know you have to you have to do
your ground work you have to
speak to candidates to get leads if you
don't speak to candidates you don't get
leads
you have to map out clients okay there's
so and elements of it
which are boring but fundamental
you know so i never like run in
but it was a core part of what i did and
you know this
a lot of elements in recruitment that
you're not gonna like that you have to
do
yeah so quickly then
how would you describe early days of
nicolas bernard then
just you smashing out at home how would
you describe
those early years well working from home
i didn't like it
because you know it's it's very easy to
be comfortable and distracted
definitely for me and
i think i wanted at the time i remember
that i wanted to have i lost
engagement with colleagues and you know
just
general camaraderie you're in the office
so when my business partner um richard
joined in 2013 and we got an office in
shoreditch
i thought great i can get up and go to
work again
and yeah it was great it was great but
you know we still had us ups and downs
it wasn't okay now we're in the office
and we're smashing it
you know so there was ups and downs in
that
okay so um what
what advice would you give then to a
younger donovan starting this business
um just
well i found that there was a bit of an
illusion at first because
you know i had the whole world that i
could contact
and there was no restrictions but then
it's like okay
i can speak to everyone and anyone
but then where do i actually start so
you know it's you always need to just
focus in on one territory focus in an
area
you know like you said double down like
i hear you say on many of your podcasts
you need to have just like a beer
specialist in one area then you or one
client
and then you could branch out you know
so
um i think at the at first i wasn't as
focused i was just running around the
market just trying to chase anyone
trying to get deals
yeah within sap but even that is too
vague
um okay so when when um
uh richard came in then what would you
say was the biggest impact
it like what was the biggest impact
richard had or him personally
or just having another human being
involved because it was just sharon and
i think a lot of people
are quite worried about starting a
business on on a recruitment business on
their own
so like what would you say were sort of
the best things about
having someone involved in your
recruitment business
well for one you don't want to let your
business partner down
accountability accountability absolutely
so
you know you don't want to be late
because then you don't want
you don't want that person to think oh
he's taking a piss or you don't want to
have another day off or half a day
you want people to think okay yeah
the person that i'm in this with is
great you know if i'm going to war with
someone
i would want to go we'll go to war with
that person so it makes you raise your
standards because you're no longer
you're no longer just keeping yourself
uh
answering yeah you're not just hurting
yourself yeah precisely
precisely so you know it slowly added a
bit more
form and shape to it being a small
business
and you know i'm a very process
orientated person so
you know it was just another piece of
the puzzle of a system that was being
created that
you know let us scale eventually
you know to be the company we are today
how how easy did you find it
having to like answer to someone else or
you can
you know i mean like i don't know like
did you find that difficult
no to be quite honest we don't answer to
each other but it's
you know it's obviously a respect thing
where you want
you know we always communicate and
um you want everything to always be
clear crystal clearance
yeah it always has been to be fair you
know if you do
if you do the something in the best
possible way
then other people will see that and
you know it doesn't it doesn't become a
question of answering to someone else
okay so richard jordan in 2013
and then you didn't make your your first
r until when was that
roughly so we hired 2000
in july 2017. okay
so yeah solid four years of obviously
yeah building so like what
what like did you guys have a plan when
richard joined like what was the plan
tell us a bit about
what the intentions were for those two
to four years with richard being
involved
so the first plan was for us to build as
much as possible
and just pay off large chunks of our
mortgages off
okay and we will just absolutely smash
it out
yeah and then we would just you know
both put in
you know a percentage or a part of our
billions into a pot and then that port
finances hires
so um yeah we had
we both both got to a level that we had
some solid villains
you know and uh yeah we went for it give
us some context
just youtube what tell us how long it
took attraction what you was you guys
billing
because it's all contract to sap yeah so
i was billing
about 240 a year and richmond was doing
the same and then we started employing
but
do you know even with that a lot of
people think okay well um you know
i'll just set up and just do it all
myself but
it's it's a lot harder than that because
you've got to
you can't just be a biller you've got to
be a businessman you've got to be able
to set up a system
you know or you can't just have one
lucky year
where you know you've come across a
client and you know they're hiring lows
and then
it all goes bad you know because then if
you start hiring people and
you don't have that solid foundation
of crying giving you jobs or clients
giving you jobs then
you know you could find yourself a bit
in a sticky situation so
you know we was both billing at 240
grand
you know for the year and we had a solid
base where we could just thought okay
this is a platform that we can actually
go and create something with let's just
talk a bit about that platform donovan
then let's talk about the sort of last
three years because i think that's
interesting right so like what you did
in the
so basically what you've done there is
you've de-risked
the risk of hiring more people and
growing the business right but yeah
building a platform
i'm assuming there's maybe some systems
that you thought about as well we might
have some sort of key accounts but like
what what when you say platform talk to
us a bit about that because i think some
people benefit from that who are
thinking maybe they want to grow this
business but not sure of
when to hire or like where to get to do
you know what i mean so you mentioned a
bit about billings and revenue that
you're bringing into the company but
yeah what what
what was the sort of i guess what were
you richard aiming for
to to get to for you guys to have
confidence and be like right
let's start trying to grow this thing
now yeah so i'm sure
it could be i don't know and in terms of
monies-wise you wanted saving where you
gave yourself a six-month 12-month
runway or
it might have been certain systems like
what was you
getting to for you to guys be like right
let's let's get more people involved and
try and grow this business
well to be quite honest is when we had
won the market was really good we got to
a point where we had
you know a good amount of money in the
business
and that we had refined our systems our
database was
you know pretty much spot on and we just
thought the time was right to be quite
honest okay
um plus also
it's also down it was also down to our
natural progression
as individuals because realistically if
you're a one
band recruiter you're just a recruiter
aren't you but for you to evolve
and get to that next level you need to
have people underneath you to manage
leading coach
you know so the time was right and we
felt that
you know we had had a good spell but we
wanted
that next level and
that new challenge in terms of you know
bringing people on and
training them up okay and so forth yeah
so how did you go about this in dublin
because donovan because you're
in a you're in you're in london yeah
there's a lot of recruitment businesses
in london
it's your rich hashing it out like how
how did you go about
getting people into this business and
not for the challenge i think that
that's one of the biggest
challenges for a lot of recruitment
businesses with smaller grown businesses
to like
how did you then did you get people
without experience at the start did you
just so you just hired one person or did
you
hire quite a few initially talk to us a
bit about how you
how you aimed at growing it so basically
we um
we hired grads or
we hired inexperienced recruiters
people that had some sales experience
and uh we just trained them all up so we
we put together a training program um
and yeah we just had some
good hands-on we were like they're
mentors
like you go to the gym
and you have a personal trainer but it's
just like that so we hired
our first consultant in july 2017
we hired one and then we hired our
second employee
um in october 2017
and you know things were all going good
then 2018
february we hired two two more at a time
and you know we thought okay well let's
just limit the work it's the same
training
you know we had the cash we had the we
had the
the funds to be able to facilitate it
and then we just kept on hiring
probably like uh you know two every
five to six months okay so
when you say training i know you just
mentioned there was like hands on stuff
like that
just give us a bit of a flavor of that
because i think that's where
i think it comes back to systems doesn't
it and i'm assuming that you're thinking
well if we have
a training program now where we are then
that hopefully will
come in handy when we get to 20 30 40
people right
so i guess what like some recruitment
owners that
are sort of where you're at they may
think well i'll give them a phone and
then i'll sort of just
answer their questions and stuff like
that like what what were what were the
what did that training program actually
consist of of interest
well to be quite honest it's
there was no glossy you know handouts it
was
just getting on the phones and doing
the work right but we would be listening
to
you know all of the calls they would
literally be sat next to us and after
every call
we would be like okay the candidate said
this
it means this
therefore you've got two options you can
either do that
or this alternative and this is what you
get in both situations
so it was like a case study on every
call
you know and that and and and we found
that
people would learn a lot better
a lot more should we say then you know
some of the bigger companies
are just like all right here's some
numbers here's the phone just crack on
you know so it was really just
proper coaching should we say yeah okay
and um look it's something that people
are always interested in
donovan like and i think back to the
first question there's so many different
things that well there's so many
different types of successful recruiters
different backgrounds or whatever but
like
over the sort of last yeah three four
years where you've
consistently hired now like what are
your non-negotiables when
hiring for your business like what do
you what do you look for and yes work
ethic and these things but like what do
you actually look for what are the
non-negotiables for you
um
so you know we haven't always got it
right
but we've got it right more often than
not
is just pure drive and hunger you know
i i don't really i'm not bothered about
if
you know someone comes from money good
upbringing because
well i'm not going to generalize but if
you've had hardship
if you haven't really had much in life
there's a chance that you're going to be
more hungry to go and get it to make it
happen
so that's what we personally look for
you know we look for a hungry
you know just diamonds in the dirt
seriously that's what we look for
diamonds in the dirt and you know we
polish them up
we'll give them a chance you know a lot
of the people they probably
wouldn't you know they wouldn't have
been seen
by the bigger the bigger more corporate
recruitment companies you know we'll
just you know
if you can sell if you've got that drive
then yeah well
we're interested what are we looking for
here then donovan like a rough
like a backstory like i had it hard when
i was younger
i'm here to like you know what i mean
are you digging for that with people
no to be quite honest it's like
everyone's got to be themselves
you know but we've hired some people
that you know dress well
and you know they're quite polished and
then
when they come and you know they say
they want to be successful they say they
do this
but then it's like okay i'll call this
client later well no call him now
oh i just tried him once or twice no
gotta be on it you've got to be on it
because
every time you're not on it and calling
and making it happen you know when
you're racing with your competitors on
that job believe me they're going to
harass
that client that candidate it comes down
to drive
so where people don't have it in them to
you know
just just not just be persistent
you know that's that's that's what
that's what we look for people that are
just
they need to earn money you know
if we think that you don't need to earn
money if you've got it too
easy then look it's better that you know
they go to some of the bigger companies
because you gotta understand yeah
look when we started we didn't have an
external back in
you know we just did it all organic so
we've gone for a slower approach where
we're training up
people ourselves and yeah we want to
obviously we're a business we need to
see our return so we need to hire people
that want to change their lives that
want to make an impact
you know in in the set recruitment world
and would you say like that training and
your time
has been more so than not worth the
investment
100 yeah 100 because it's like
it's definitely worth the investment
because you're
[Music]
you're you're buying
you're you're employing people when
they're cheaper
and then you're training them up you
know it's like
you're getting it's like you know being
arsenal that you know develops youth
academy
and then they grow into to players you
know obviously
it's it's it's definitely worth an
investment but
i went to the recruitment fair i think
it was last february
not this fabric on the the one before
that and one of the speakers i can't
remember who they said that look you
can't build
a recruitment company on inexperienced
recruiters
really yeah yeah you know on grads in
experience i mean once that you're a
certain size you can bring an academy
and just bring an l d person and then
just train them up and
you know just ten in eight out at the
end of the month
two states but you know
we've we've done a good job of it so far
but
obviously it's going to come to a point
where we're probably looking at
more experienced recruiters but yeah
it's worked for us so far
okay so
what what were some of the sort of key
ingredients to
nicholas bernard going from yeah you you
and
um your business partner doing 500k or
so revenue between you
then hiring people to to now yeah
largely did the 8 million in turnover
like what were some of the
sort of key things that you think has
enabled you to to get to that point
because that's
that's that's an amazing achievement but
if you think of that
obviously you're a small business right
so to be generating that
that's great so like what what were some
of the sort of so you're mentioning
around the people training them up the
right types of people that
you're getting into the business but
what what else do you think that you and
richard
have sort of had to change or um have
implemented that
has enabled you to to achieve
turnover like that to be quite honest
it's
having market information and going for
quality clients
right when things started to go really
good for us is because we had
some we had a strategy
and this strategy was complemented with
having a couple of key clients that
enabled us to
deliver and have a good financial
you know platform for us to grow you
know
so focusing on certain key clients
in regions and yeah just
just being able to deliver on them but
that comes with having
the market knowledge being a subject
matter expert in in your fields
you know what so let's talk about that
because i think a lot of
like hopefully you agree but a lot of
recruiters get fixate and this has come
out from some of the conversations
recently where
i had a um chat called um oliver on from
faden international that
a global organization scaled to 800
staff and
they've done really well in america and
one of the things that he
thinks is the the key reason why is that
they
really impacted the culture of instead
of sort of
getting a new client doing really well
then
rinse and repeat with the next new
client new client actually what they
ended up doing is
yeah focusing on key clients expanding
those accounts
they ended up building a whole team
client services team
that then turned i don't know six figure
accounts into
seven figure accounts right so
from your perspective what was you
looking for that you think
or gave you more confidence that these
could be a key client or a good client
like what were you looking for what were
you trying to gather and understand
well to be quite honest we we started to
have a different
approach so a lot of our competitors
were
supplying sap resources
across europe and we started to branch
out further afield so
you know since 2014 we started doing
lots in the us we had some key accounts
that focused
our delivery in the u.s and asia so we
weren't just
another recruitment company doing
you know prospecting for the european
markets but we were able to follow
implementation projects globally
and you know there were certain
regions where we didn't really have much
competition
you know and that allowed us to really
you know just form a partnership and
yeah the billions and billions rose with
with those partnerships so
you know in 2016 we suffer
a c-corp in the u.s the plan is to um
because we did probably about 50 of our
revenue
out in the us and you know the plan is
to
to grow that part and just have you know
troops
troops on the ground in the us in
probably a couple of years
okay yeah that makes sense so actually
your competitive advantage is and how
so it's actually been yeah global a
global focus
yeah and actually okay so we still had a
focus in
europe but you know it's been like you
know we can follow your implementations
across europe yeah so instead of yeah so
yeah so like you might have got a client
in europe where
you supplied x amount of people for an
implementation
yeah exactly whereas before you're what
you're saying is well actually
we made sure or we aimed to start
working with clients that didn't just
have an eu operation or whatever they
had
yeah global footprint which meant we
deliver well here then it's like right
who's dealing with your asian
implementation whatever we can supply
that blah blah blah right exactly
so so let's talk about this and don when
you're someone that's bilingual
right there are you may you may have
noticed this but there's definitely more
uk agencies going to america
there's more uk agencies just focusing
in the eu markets
so talk about the nuances that you've
had to adapt to like
what have you had to change in your
approach or what have you had to learn
about the american culture
that you've had to adapt to a lot of
people are interested on if i'm
if i've typically been a uk recruiter
but i've heard the fees in america are
much
larger or um actually there's a real op
like the uk is just completely saturated
i'm just gonna do
amsterdam and this skill set or whatever
like
let's talk about america first if
because i think that's that's quite
popular what like
what have you had to adapt to what
things have you picked up on that you're
going oh
that's a bit interesting i'll make sure
i don't do that next time or
what have been the main differences that
you've picked up on
well the more we started to do um
the more we started to trade in the us
the more
our clients or prospects clients would
ask if we had a local entity out there
and they didn't want to be invoiced by a
european company or a foreign company
and there was a lot of you know
bureaucracy
and just a lot of paperwork a lot of
hoops to jump through just to avoid that
so to bypass that so we ended up setting
up a company there
and um yeah still it's been it's been
challenging because um
you know there's unless you're actually
there
it's a lot more difficult
to um gain the trust
from us clients when you're in europe or
even u.s candidates some you know some
will be like well
how do i know i'm going to get paid i
don't really want to work with a non-us
entity
you know even though the sap is a german
software european software
and i just yeah but yeah that's all fun
and games but also the hours the hours
is a killer
really yeah i was a killer yeah i was um
i was doing 14 hours a day um
coming home most nights at half day 11
yeah
still having my my phone just beefing
with emails in there
so so what about so you mentioned a bit
about yes
yeah dealing with what or have you got
an organization in america whatever
what about so one of the conversations i
had recently with um a chat
called um lewis who uh has actually
moved out to
um boston massachusetts and one of the
things that he shared
be interested to get your thoughts on
this is that um
he's had to really change his approach
in making sure that he builds
relationships with internal recruiters
and that's actually helped him open up
some big accounts whereas before
he should do the um danish market
and he would be super direct go straight
to the ceo
and wouldn't always go through the
internal recruiter but that's that's
something that
actually ended up being more damaging
than um positive
so what's been your experience in
winning accounts have you had to go for
internal recruiters have you had to
adapt that or what's been your
experience with that
no not really no we haven't really had
to to do that in the us
um to be quite honest i think where the
u.s market is different is that you've
got a 180 model which is basically just
you know someone that's just doing
delivery and then
you have someone that's just
focusing on business development you
don't really have much
of 360 recruiters now from the client
point of view it was literally
just i.t directors or
erp managers that we would all well that
would always be speaking to
so i don't think it was you know
that different to i mean i think this is
going to depend on the sector that
you're invited
yeah it's not going to be that different
to um the setup in europe to be quite
honest
okay interesting so um
look so what um what's helped you get
through the last
six or so months donovan how have they
been
um yeah it's uh it's
it's brought us back down to reality
it's uh
definitely been humbling but look we
we've had good we've run the business in
a very good way so
you know we've we're still financially
healthy
we're still making a profit you know we
still haven't had to use
any of our savings as a business even
though that we've
we're in the you know the worst crisis
human race has ever seen um look if you
do good things in the good times
then in the bad times you should be good
you know as long as you've got
discipline again you know
and you're doing good processes
then you know it makes the hard times
easier to survive now
um you know we were we were very good we
topped up everyone's photos you know
that we paid everyone
extra 20 we paid everyone full
commission
and you know some of our a lot of our
competitors and i heard a lot of other
agencies were paying half commission 43
or whatever it is you know we paid
everyone 100 commission and we topped up
people's photos so
um because we had a good good solid
foundation
um but yeah it has been hard you know we
have
what's been what's been your biggest
challenge
the biggest challenge is well look we
[Music]
not all of our sales force and all of
our recruiters
were experienced so
having people which are still training
and got you know less than the years
experience
working from home remotely when they
still need
guidance that's challenging you know so
when locked lockdown happens
smashing it out yeah well this is it and
when lockdown happens and you've
got runners that are finishing left
right center and you don't have the
workforce which is
you know working to to
to add to the runner base that obviously
becomes
a big challenge so yeah because i've
i've heard that a lot
of them was did you do you have
conversations where
or did you literally go from x amount of
contractors out
to dramatically dropping by i don't know
50 75 percent which you then had to
build up or
i've heard yeah yeah like how yeah
definitely
what was the thought process then would
you like oh my god are we literally
going to have
go from x runners to zero because it's
like when you're in the ring
so go ahead i was just gonna say i've
heard a new
number of stories so i spoke to a guy
the other day who um
was in um he's always done contract he
was in construction
and literally he went from a six seven k
grand book it was just him um to a
couple hundred quid
overnight yeah well you know
it's just like when you're in the ring
so you know if you're in the ring and
someone comes at you and they want to
take your head off
you're not going to panic you've got to
have composure you've got to believe in
your skills
believe in your processes believe in
your strategy
and you just just gotta work the game so
you know look this is a cycle so we're
in the down cycle now
we've we've built the business in a
certain way that
we have to you know keep at it and
carry on giving our best and training
our employees and make sure that
everyone
understands that this is the hardest
it's going to be for the next
12 years or so because recessions happen
every 12 years
you know the credit crunch last time and
the
net bubble um which burst you know in
2001 whenever it was in the year 2000 so
every 12 years or so there's a side call
now this is the hardest gonna be
so people have to believe in our
leadership
they have to believe in the system they
have to understand what's going on in
the world and
everything the good days will be back
you know
you just have to carry on work harder
because
the market shrunk you know if you put
the same activity
in the good times as you're doing the
bad times
obviously it's not going to be enough
you know so
as as long as people give their all
and believe in you know our vision
then we're going to back all of our
employees and i believe we're going to
come back out on
on the other side and you know just
carry on with our growth plan
so what what i'd be interested in so
look you've been in that
environment where you've been in a ring
and it's it's do or die as you said but
like how do you communicate that as a
leader
because you you might know yeah look
this is this is really badly what he's
talking about i'm
it might be more comfortable to you to
be like right let's let's do this like
i'm ready
to to to get out and take action but how
did you then communicate that as a
leader to
your staff because i'm sure there might
be business owners or even managers
going
you know what i've sort of weathered
storms before we can do this
but it's communicating that to the
people that may not think that straight
away or
may have that place to go to do you know
what i mean
well to be quite honest
we don't just wait for the bad times to
try and communicate a message
you know we've communicated messages in
the good times so
to all of my you know to all of my
employees
i used to tell them about okay well look
guys you don't know how good the market
is
you know in the recession in the credit
crunch
there was times where we weren't
probably picking up a job for
you know a couple of weeks you know if
you've got a job a month in my
you know sometimes you know i
experienced that in that times and
they couldn't believe it because they
were used to picking up you know quite a
few a week
and then when the pandemic happened it
was like well look guys remember what i
was saying
you know about what it was like now
you've earned your stripe now you
this is where you're going to earn a
badge because you're being a recruiter
in the recession
this is when you're going to learn how
to recruit when the market contracts
and when we get through this you're
going to be a better recruiter
you know so we're constantly
coaching and and and giving them the
message
you know not just now that coroner's
here and
ruining all of our lives but you know we
was you know just
building them up and building the
beliefs and making them understand how
good the market was
you know well before this pandemic
so look what one or two things before um
i ask you some
quick file questions donovan um
be really interesting to get your
thoughts on this so in
in your opinion um could refer to
yourself or
sort of people you've been around in
your career or your employees but
um what would you say or what do you
think is the most important action
or kpi that contributes to
a recruiter's success
hmm this is an interesting one
i've worked with i've worked with
million pound billers
that just bash the phone out every day
for four hours a day
i've worked with million pound billers
that we're just street savvy
just you know pure hunger
and i've worked with very successful
probably more average joes
and process orientated person
but the number one trait that they all
had
that they all had was outworking the
competition
no matter how much charisma you have no
matter how much
flair how much knowledge that you have
hard work beats talent all day long
so the kpi kpi is not a specific one
it's the volume
that they do it yeah i mean like you've
got to work smart obviously because
you know the world's changing times are
changing
i mean you know now it's a lot more
you know there's a lot of ai and email
focus email campaign and marketing but
look however
however the times you have to work hard
i think your number one
attribute you have to be a hard worker
yeah you know if you don't work hard if
you don't if
the phone's not going to call itself you
know cry it's not gonna
you know just give it to you so you've
just gotta go and make it happen
you know but like i said with the
different types of
very successful recruiters that i've
worked with they all
bloody worked hard you know
um and and and final thing before i ask
you these
questions is because i think you're very
well positioned if i'm a
recruitment consultant or or business
owner
sort of this period has probably really
showed me that i do need to not have
all my client base in uk and actually
internationalizing and having more of
the
um international footprint can actually
diversify my business and give me more
chance of
dealing with difficult times what would
be your like
three best bits of advice for me as a
recruitment consultant or business owner
to
take my recruitment desk or market
international
would you say
so basically how to position yourself
internationally because
yeah so like so i think a lot of people
during this period
may have made gone you know what i i
know america's
not as bad i'm going to go over there
and try and win some business there
whatever so
i guess what i'd be keen just to get
from you because you have worked in
always really international markets if
that's
eu brazil whatever like what would be
your three best bits of advice for me if
i'm
re i've recognized that my sector
there's an opportunity to not just do it
in the uk where it's more saturated
i could actually diversify and pick up
business in the eu
or america or whatever what would be
your free business advice for me to do
that to do that well
i mean if in my field it's multinational
companies so
if you're dealing with a client in
europe
there's a big chance that they're going
to have an entity in the us
an entity in asia so if you're dealing
with europe
why not you know start trying to deal
with them in the u.s
and in asia so you've you're literally
it's a warm core
it's a warm relationship but you've got
to be able to
back that delivery and have a candidate
pool
in the us or in asia so you need to
build that
that candidate network um to be able to
reflect that
um you know with that you need to
understand
the networks because
if you're trying to pitch people in the
u.s and you don't understand the us
rates
and or the the different
you know business culture in a specific
market
then you're going to fall flat on your
face and obviously
every region has got different
compliance
you know if if you're you know there's
withholding taxes there's different
um ways of doing business so you've got
to really understand
you know what you can and can't do
in different markets because you know
um if client doesn't pay you then yeah
it's gonna hurt you know if
if if you haven't you know incorporated
if you haven't
figured out that is withholding taxes
and you know a country's got 20
withholding tax then yeah that's your
margin gone
to the tax to the tax man
um i've got five questions for you
donovan okay
okay and we'll finish so first one
if you could change the industry what
would you improve
if i could change the industry
um if i could change the industry well i
think linkedin's changed it
yeah i think linkedin has really uh
changed industry i mean
it's put everyone on
a semi even
like position where yeah where you don't
have to be a specialist
you can just put an advert out you don't
have to be a specialist in sap
you can just have big budgets you know
put loads of adverts out on linkedin
and you can reach the same people that
you know we reach to but not as fast as
us because this is what we do all day
every day so what would you want to
improve then so what would you want to
improve about the recruitment industry
if you could change it to be quite
honest i think it's all going down
it's all going down an automation and ai
i think the i hope it doesn't
but i think that human touch element i
can see
it going down an automation part which i
think
could kill the industry in years to come
but
yeah that's what i would want to prevent
to be quite honest
what book have you read that has had the
biggest impact on you
um it's quite a few but
rich dad poor dad's too cashflow
quadrant
if you want to set up a business you
need to understand
what a business really is because a lot
of people work for themselves
they think they own a business but they
don't they're just self-employed
so rich dad poor dad one is a good
introduction but
cash flow quadrant that's the real one
like it so if donovan could write
a linkedin post that could be seen by
every single recruitment consultant
across the world
what would you want it to say oh you
really feel the spot now
haven't you um what would you want it to
say
yeah what would i want it to say
what i wanted to say to be quite honest
i don't really know
i'm not going to [ __ ] you no i don't
be in the spot okay that's fine
you can tell i'm not a blagger i'm real
all right
what did you spend your first biggest
commission paycheck on
what that's been my first biggest
question what as in when i was
first started whenever whenever just
whenever like whenever
to be quite honest i bought i bought my
flat straight away so i really said
yeah i bought a flat in literally within
the first i was
i was pretty much in my first year of
recruitment and
it was in 2005 and i just put all my
money and just bought a flat i'm
i'm a builder i'm about you know just
growing and making it happen and once
yeah then you could be a bit more flashy
yeah yeah you know it's it's
it's only in the last probably five
years that i've started going on
lots of holidays and just being a bit
more
you know just splashing out yeah
enjoying your hard work this is it and
this is it and there was times where you
know i wasn't doing any of that because
i was just accumulating and grinding and
yeah then you just gotta cash in last
question
what is the ultimate goal for your
recruitment career
or your recruitment entrepreneurial
journey what's your ultimate goal oh my
goal
um i would like to have
i'll let's have a big big
a big conglomerate of recruitment
companies
in different continents
different brands doing different
technologies
and yeah just be seen as a leader as a
pioneer
donovan it's been a pleasure thank you
hisham it's been a pleasure as well